votre attention s'il vous plaît que nous
accueons une nouvelle élès bien tu
veuxon l'impression
d'reb pas ce que je veux c'est juste ce
qui se passe sux je
[Musique]
ration tu
m'entends et on va la faire payer les
fill sont perturbé par des hormones
INR
hor que c'est
char pouro tu l' depu la 6è ton cor s
transformé en
grandissant si vous voulez me parler de
quoi que ce soit de problème de cœur ou
de PO noir ou de com j'ai connu tout ça
je peux vous
[Musique]
assurer Rachel Hamilton rempl son
inhalateur de vodka c'est comme ça qu'on
l'utilise déchirer tous mes
rêves déchir comme si personne regard
mais tout le monde vous regarde parce
que vous êtes des stars allez inger ah
quoi qu'est-ce que c'est du poil auobob
je
[Musique]
rêve